mi chiamo mila metri e sono una
ricercatrice
dell'università cattolica di piacenza e
mi occupo di insetti particolari degli
altri
mi ricordo quando da bambina di ricorso
delle colline piacentine con i miei
genitori perché no una casetta in un
paesino di lo migliore e guardano verso
una che non sa pagana quella coltre di
nebbia comincino sa che sembrava sotto
par è tutto
chissà forse da lì è nato in interessi
nei confronti dell'inquinamento e di
questo io oggi vorrei parlarvi di mi
lamento ma anche di api
se noi fossimo
all'interno di cambiare se in grembo
questo frastuono al frastuono
generato dalle armi di decine di miglia
ne diamo tutte femmine tutte sterili
perché all'interno della famiglia di
armi c'è solo una femmina fertile questa
è la reggina la reggina si con in
primavera con i maschi e trattiene
all'interno del proprio corpo in una
sacca del tasto era una teca disperato
di sony con questi seconda luna di prova
che depone a migliaia
all'interno dell'alveare dal loro
seconda to machine ma piccola l'araba
che viene nutrita alle altre terapie con
una sorta di latte se vogliamo si chiama
papà se la piccola barba di entry ma
sempre solo come papabile si supera una
regina fertile se dopo tre giorni le app
per anni decidono di fare una piccola
l'arma evitarle come cibo quello che
mangiano tutti gli accaduti che è una
miscela di mieli polline l'araba si
trasformerà in una più teheran è sede
anche se sterile però l'aria in pedana
compie
sciogliere i buoni molto importanti
all'interno famiglie gli anni per le
prime tre settimane circa sta
all'interno della mia auto dei provini
giorgio diversi compiti ad esempio tu
dicevi cellule nutre avvicina e le
sorelline con la pappa reale
aiuta nella costruzione della bianca
ceva dalla stessa segreta trasforma in
lettere in ieri e così via ma dopo
queste tre settimane si porta
all'esterno della e diventa arte
bottinatrici chi è quel lato e che lui
dei angolari su fiori in primavera e in
estate riva la ricerca dell'elemento
delle api quale incide delle api in
metri che trasformato il miele
rappresenta la fonte di zuccheri della
tia terminati e polline che invece
rappresenta la fonte di liquidità
ipoteca e per raccogliere nei tre uomini
leali ideali compiono voli quotidiani
avanti indietro dalla inviare tutti i
giorni per centi manici rivali di
mentine anche km e alla fine muoiono
decine
e la raccolta del polline
sfrutta una proprietà fisica della
materia che noi tutti conosciamo perché
che cosa succede se ci strillano forti
le mani sui valori da oggi spazio gli
anni di broso nevicata
creiamo
elettricità la prima di marzo corpo è
rivestito di fitti simply che durante il
buono e le attività della cultura lo
strega
deboli dell'area e gli uni contro gli
altri cremo cariche elettriche e quindi
l'area così caricata si avvicina azione
e attira su di se i grandi parchi latte
quindi sicuri cefa quelle palline di
polline che noi vediamo attaccata
personalizzabili posso essere gialle
rosse arancioni del fus
ma queste carte di crosta che non attira
non soltanto un po linee partiranno
anche gli inquinanti in particolare le
polveri sottili che sanno di serre se
non fosse che si depositano sulle
superfici che cosa sono i polveri
sottili tutti abbiamo sentito parlare di
pm10 pienamento e mezzo pieno è stata
nel partito m ora particolari e quel
numero 10 2 m sta ad indicare le
dimensioni finissime di queste polveri
reso invisibile appunto 10 10 micron 10
millesimi
e l'esposizione pasti con può provocare
seri danni alla salute ad esempio se
inalate al sistema respiratorio
oppure al sistema cardiovascolare al
sistema gastrointestinali suggerite
pensate che esistono porre ancora pensi
le polveri ultrafini onda sottili pm 01
trave nei piccoli che sembrano non avere
barba alle barriere ideologiche cioè
possono in segnalate per sé tra
l'identità menti del circolo sanguigno e
distribuirsi all'interno del corpo
secondo alcuni ricercatori polverini tra
fini ne parli che sono stati ritrovati
nel cervello dei malati di alzheimer il
parkinson quindi potrebbero essere
responsabili anche di patologie
neurodegenerative
quali sono le fonti di emissioni delle
polveri
beh ci sono condivisione naturali come
incendi deduzioni fiscali ma anche la
natura l'illusione moderata dalla
pioggia vento sui suoni posto di un
territorio ma con le proprie attività
può produrre epatico
pensiamo ad esempio a un'attività
industriale di tipo di sara un'attivita
di costruzione
un'attività agricola all'incenerimento
dei rifiuti
anche il traffico può immettere nuove
come le sottili e tra l'altro se
nell'immaginario collettivo gli
imminenti legati ridicoli i pirati dei
di libri sono legati al turi scappamento
per ripondere sottili non è così c'è una
fonte di emissione ancorato importante e
cioè sono i freni e quindi le pastiglie
che strega contro i dischi dei freni
sono
versioni delle parti nei campi lo
sfregamento degli pneumatici passato e
quindi non sono i combustibili fossili e
ovviamente veicoli pesanti producono più
bombe dei leggeri paradossalmente le
auto elettriche che sono in proporzioni
ri pesanti dei libri come scenari perché
ha una batteria e mettono più molti dare
loro passivi dei segni e dei pneumatici
e reali beh abili che ora in ambienti
inquinati da polveri sottili portano sul
proprio corpo questa contaminata simone
e noi possiamo vederla con un
microscopio elettronico a scansione
eccole le polveri sottili the contano le
ali delle armi il microscopio
elettronico a fortissimo in grandi
medici mostra tutti questi punti vi
brillanti
immagini delle ali quasi in cielo
stellato
possiamo osservare anche maggiori
ingrandimento e viviamo anche delle
morfologie delle forme particolari
attenzione perché la forma delle polveri
boati darci indicazioni sulle fonti di
emissioni ad esempio queste polveri seri
che derivano da combustioni adatta
copertura come quelle che possono
avvenire all'interno di un i genitori di
geni tipici di unindustria senologica
con una sonda raggi ics possiamo anche
studiare la composizione chimica delle
polveri sottili quindi sapere anche di
chi possa sono fatto fare il loro
rischio il conto secolò gico e questo
bellissimo cielo stellato di contamina
questi anni limate deriva tutto dal
pratico di volare sono quelle a vasi di
ferro marchi di parete fini e di trani
quindi se con seminari si sporcano
chiaramente ci indicano che l'ambiente
inquinato poteri ap solo un foro di la
bdb indicato dello stato di salute
dell'ambiente le armi fu la pacatezza
nuovo e quindi quello che solca muro può
recare alla nostra salute
che cosa possiamo fare quindi per
limitare l'esposizione a questi
pericolosi inquinanti
bene anche in questo la qui ci dà un
suggerimento perché l'album è il simbolo
di una tra le più fruttuose
collaborazioni diciamo simbiosi tra un
animali e le piante la riprende il
civico per piante immettere poi nega
fornisce che con scritto elezioni e
quindi dovremmo promuovere la nostra
collaborazione con verde e quindi
evitare di tagliare le piante
evitare future ma teste che riconducono
alla morte che apparissimo gli altri ma
anche soprattutto
siriano gusti segnalati cimenti
prendersi cura del basso verde ea del
tessuto vitalismo
chiti inquinanti comprese le polveri
sottili rispetto che avrebbe un tessuto
non vivo come può essere cene passate in
carico a nostro verde ci dà anche
rossino cinetica gli effetti del clima e
locali ci può dare anche ci dice
infine
la rai ha chiuso discutibili
pensiamoci i fieri
offrono bellezza e noi ci troviamo qui a
piacenza e il nome della città di
piacenza pari dell'eni proprio da questo
da quanto piacevole e lei apparisse la
natura attorno a questo piccolo
insediamento quando scendeva le colline
ricordiamoci infatti che l'uomo e parte
degli ecosistemi l'uomo è natura e in
quanto tali non potrà mai restare sordo
alla bellezza e alla semplicità dei suoi
viviamo